all right let's talk about one of the
most exciting
uh technologies like technically
philosophically
like socially financially in every way
which is ethereum 2.0
there's a million things to talk about
but at the step one
is probably a good thing to do which is
can you briefly summarize your vision
how ethereum 2.0 will make ethereum more
scalable
secure and sustainable sure
so i think recently we've actually been
kind of de-emphasizing the
east 2.0 branding i guess so the reason
behind that was that
originally we envisioned something more
like a big grand event
where you know all the good things would
happen at the same time and it would be
a new blockchain
and it would be a new protocol and
people would have to take a lot of
effort to migrate over
but later we've slowly change the road
map over to something that's much more
incremental
um right so you know proof of stake
happens kind of over time and then
charting gets added over time and all
these features get added over time
and so the experience for just a regular
ethereum user
still feels very seamless right it's
like maybe a little bit more complex
than the hard forks that we've already
done but from a user's point of view but
like
not by that much right so like the big
two things that are happening right
these are what used to be considered the
two flagship features of e3.0 and now
they're just you know
the flagship features of the you know
the next uh
evolution of ethereum yeah as uh proof
of stake
and sharding right so proof of stake is
a consensus algorithm it's
a the or it's not just mechanism i
should say um it's
the difference is that like an algorithm
is something that you run by yourself a
mechanism is like
it involves interactions between people
and it could even include incentives and
all of that
uh so the consensus mechanism
uh so by which nodes in uh
the network agree on you know which
blocks came in which transactions came
in in what order
uh make sure that once a block gets
accepted it can't get reverted and all
of these
things that we expect from a blockchain
um so
existing blockchains you know including
bitcoin including the ethereum of today
and including
a lot of them they use proof of work
right uh so
the reason why we need proof of anything
is be it is because like they serve this
function that i call kind of economic
civil resistance
so that's obviously you know a big word
for
especially if you've never heard of
sybil's before but like the basic idea
is right that you have a network and you
have lots of computers that
agree on like which block to accept and
sometimes you get you know two blocks
that get published at the same time and
you just have to agree on an order so
there
has to be some kind of voting game yeah
but then the question is well in this
voting game
you know who get who gets a vote who
gets to participate
now the pro you can't say one person one
vote right the reason why you cannot say
one person one vote is because
you need some kind of like authority or
some kind of mechanism to say you know
who the
the humans are like and if you don't
have that then
a bad guy could just come in with a
virtual machine or with a computer that
has on it
10 billion virtual machines that have 10
billion you know virtual nodes
and then just like say look i'm 99 of
the network i should control everything
uh so to prevent this what proof of work
and proof of stake both do
is they basically say well the weight of
your vote like how much influence
your votes have in the consensus
is proportional to like what quantity of
economic resources you bring in
so in the case of proof-of-work you
prove what economic resources you have
because your economic resources are
computers
and you prove that you have them by just
running them 24 7 using one of these
hash algorithms right
so this does solve the problem right
because in order to attack the network
you have to come in with more computers
or and
more money invested into computers and
electricity than
the rest of the network puts together
and that's extremely expensive
in proof-of-stake instead of relying on
uh people with computers that are
just constantly cranking out hashes 24 7
you
as you're like a unit of economic
resources you just use like holdings of
coins inside the system
right so all of these blockchains they
have some kind of coin in them bitcoin
has bitcoin ethereum has ether
um you know they all have a coin so why
not just use that as
the economic the economic resource that
you're using to like measure
participation
um so that's like the core
distinction between proof of work and
proof of stake um
i like proof of steak and i've liked
proof of steak for many years
basically because like it just requires
much
less ongoing resource consumption right
like with proof-of-work
um you know you have to like actually go
and buy these physical computers
and these days um you know yeah they
have specialized hardware asics
application specific integrated circuits
you have to go produce them you have to
go buy them
and unless you have millions of dollars
you know you have to buy them from one
of these other people who creates them
and those other people often end up
taking a huge cut of the profits
themselves
uh and then you know you have to plug
them in you have to just
um burn all of this electricity that's
just um running 24 7. so
it consumes a huge amount of energy
right and it gets not just
energy it also you know just to create
the hardware right like people focus a
lot on energy but like actually
about half the cost of proof of work
mining is the cost of the hardware
um so hardware is a very big deal too um
and you know you need this like these
this really big and powerful
very specialized hardware another kind
that fills up these big warehouses
so proof of stake you don't you don't
really need that much electricity you
just need
just a little bit to run right to run a
regular computer
you can run proof of stake validators on
computers that you already have
um so it's just much
less resource intensive and like this is
good for a few reasons right like one is
you know the kind of environmental
rationale that
you know you're not breaking the
environment um the second
is that you're not taking away
electricity
and like other resources from other
people right like right now there's
i think just today i saw a story about
like iran wanting to shut down
some bitcoin mining because it was just
grabbing up so much electricity that it
was you know outbidding the nearby towns
and they just
didn't have enough um and then there was
like chia that was the one that's doing
proof of like hard disk mining basically
it's just like grabbing up so many hard
disks there's a
there's a shortage right so that's the
second reason and then
the third more selfish reason is that
because participating in consensus
does not require so much energy
expenditure you don't need to pay people
as much to participate right
so like bitcoin and ethereum they both
issue
somewhere around four percent of the
total supply every year right now
to miners so ethereum is about 4.7
million ether
and the current supply is about 115
million but with proof of stake like we
expect it'll be somewhere between
500 000 and one and one million per year
um so so that means you know this
the supply doesn't have to increase so
quickly
um so one of the pros that uh
that people sort of argue for the proof
of work is that uh it is secure because
it's much more difficult to
sort of as you've highlighted is
difficult to participate
is there is what are your thoughts about
the security
of the proof-of-stake mechanism
is is there ways to make it secure so i
think proof-of-stake is very secure
because in order to be able to attack
the system you need to have like
basically as much stake as the rest of
the network right
so that means like right now for example
we have five million each taking so you
have to come up with five million eth
and then join the network
and then the the other so five million
ether's a lot right it's like
how much is it now like 15 billion
dollars so that's actually more than i
i believe the cost of um attacking the
bitcoin network
and then the second thing is that
recovering from attacks is much easier
in proof-of-stake than proof-of-work
right because
in proof-of-stake you have like first of
all we have for many kinds of attacks
that you do against this network
we have this concept of like automatic
swashing right which basically means
that
in order to like revert a finalized
block so if there's one block that's
like accepted by the network
and you try to convince the network to
kind of revert that block and accept a
different block
in order to make that kind of attack you
basically have to
have your validator like a big portion
of your validators signed
to conflicting messages and this is
something that like once
these messages are on the network well
you can go and prove like look these
people did it
and so we have this feature in the
protocol called slashing where you
basically take all these people
who provably misbehaved and you burn
their coins right and you don't burn
anyone else's coins
now there are other cases like for
example if
instead of reverting blocks the attack
just tries to censor everyone
right then what you do everyone who got
censored would just like basically
create the minority chain
um and then the community would
basically have to do a soft fork right
they would just have to say like look
this chain is clearly attacking us this
chain is the one not attacking us
and so we're going to join this chain
and then what happens is that
on that new chain the attackers also
lose a lot of coins
right yeah so the difference between
proof-of-stake and proof-of-work
is that in a proof-of-stake system like
you can identify specific participants
and you can say you know
these and like this isn't like you know
a human going in and saying i don't like
you i don't like you i don't like you
this is like automated
right you know the slashing process is
automated
yes is there ways it can go wrong so
that's a painful process where the coins
are burned
um it is painful yes i think
i mean the one big unknown of course is
like if an attack actually happens
and like if an attack happens that
requires the community to actually
choose one of these minority forks
then like what would the the community
actually successfully coordinating on
this look like right like
it's like you know we can talk about it
and we can
you know write like science fiction
novels about it but like until it's
happened you don't really know the
details of like what it looks like and
how difficult it is
what are the channels of communication
for the community if you can
enlighten me a little bit like what you
know uh
in many ways in the political realm
twitter is often used as a way to kind
of have these emerging phenomena
of large groups of people coming to a
consensus
about a particular idea and then there's
battle for consensus
what's uh in the ethereum community
how do people what are the sources
of natural language based communication
that
have an emergent belief structure that
you would say
or is it all through money is it all
through trading that the communication
happens
there's definitely talking as well um i
mean like we have to agree on protocol
changes somehow right like there's
twitter there's reddit
there's um github there's uh
all of the various ethereum forums
ethereum magicians ethereum research
there's just in-person communication
then there's just kind of like the
hidden web of everyone talking to
everyone on telegram
um or signal uh so it's like some of
everything
right but i think like the thing to
emphasize around like can you actually
come to consensus on you know whether or
not to
fork the chain because the attacker is
censoring some everyone just for example
is like you everyone who's running a
node is going to see
almost the same thing right like they're
going to be off by a few seconds and
like maybe they'll be off by a few
they'll disagree by a few minutes but
like if it's a serious attack you know
people are gonna know right it's not
like one of those things where you know
oh it
we're trying to agree on like i don't
know did epstein kill himself or like
some you know
random political facts were like in
reality no one knows a single thing
about what's actually going on and
they're all speculating
like it is much more visible right so we
do have that
but you know at the same time i'm happy
to admit that like
these are fairly untested mechanisms but
like at the same time they're also
untested mechanisms in proof of work
right
and like in proof of work it's even
harder because in proof of work you
don't have the ability to like identify
and say
like you know i'm going to these miners
attacked and so we're not going to let
these mine
these miners in these miners do not
attack so we're going to keep them in
like you have to pretty much you know
either take out none of the miners or
you do a fork that changes the proof of
work algorithm which takes out all of
the miners right so
the the economics of like recovering
from attacks and proof of work at least
to me
actually do seem more unfavorable
but you know i'm sure the proof of work
people you talk to will give
a very different and contradictory
opinions and that's totally fine and
amazing
you